70 años como reina no se celebran todos
los días y en la víspera isabel segunda
reapareció para su jubileo de platino y
además decidió que era un buen momento
para aceptar a camila como futura reina
consorte el día que su hijo carlos
ascienda al trono una sorpresa después
de haber rechazado a camila en el pasado
la casa real británica se avergonzaba de
ella por el romance secreto que mantenía
con el príncipe carlos mientras éste
estaba casado con lady de la reina
isabel segunda ya prepara su sucesión
después de unos últimos años difíciles
en las últimas navidades fue
hospitalizada y se dudó de su capacidad
para salir adelante a sus 95 años
el bajón físico se produjo meses después
de la muerte de su marido el príncipe
felipe de gales el 9 de abril de 2021
una muerte dura pero que no ha sido la
única de sus preocupaciones su otro hijo
el príncipe andrew tiene graves
problemas legales un juez de nueva york
dictaminó en enero que podía avanzar una
demanda civil contra él tras las
acusaciones de violar a una adolescente
en 2001 y está relacionado con el
magnate y delincuente sexual jeffrey
epstein antes en enero de 2020 la casa
real ya había vivido otra crisis de
imagen después de que harry nieto de
isabel 2a y su mujer megan markel
decidieron abandonar la vida real hecho
del que no se han retractado por ello en
los últimos días la reina les ha quitado
los últimos honores que les quedaban las
jefaturas de sus patronatos
y escándalos problemas de salud y
acusaciones de ser una monarquía
anacrónica en el 70 aniversario de la
reina isabel segunda sin embargo la casa
de windsor ha vivido todo tipo de crisis
en su historia las cuales siempre ha
terminado por superar